chaque jour au service de neuro
traumatologie de l'hôpital de la timone
reçoit en moyenne cinq cas de lésions
accidentelle concernant le crâne et le
rachis ce lundi 14 cents l'an dernier
soit la majorité des cas graves qui se
présente dans la région
il ya des régions qui sont des légions d
hémorragie qui ce fondateur de la boîte
crânienne et qui donc comprime le
cerveau il y a également des lésions
direct du cerveau des comme si on se
donne un coup sur un bras sur une jambe
il ya des bleus il y a des contusions
ses terres d ehden dégonflement qui se
font et comme le cerveau et à l'inter de
la boîte crânienne qui n'est pas
extensible
le cerveau se trouve comprimé par
lui-même si l'on veut et puis étant
donné que le cerveau est l'organe qui
est le plus important une lésion de ce
cerveau lui-même entraîne beaucoup de
conséquences évidemment lorsque très
important c'est le diagnostic est ce
qu'il est quels sont les moyens de
diagnostic
le diagnostic il y a eu bien sûr
l'examen clinique qui reste très valable
il faut d'abord examiner un blessé
lorsqu'il arrive mais nous avons
maintenant après avoir eu la topographie
qui nous a beaucoup peiné à l'époque
nous avons maintenant la peau rayage qui
est vraiment excellent pour nous c'est
ce qu'on appelle le scanner ce qu'on
appelle parfois la tomodensitométrie ou
d'autres noms tomographie computer risée
en général quelle est la cause de ces
lésions
très souvent il s'agit d'acide
l'accident de la circulation qu'on
appelle les accidents de trafic dans 60
70 % des cas donc et puis il ya aussi
des chutes en particulier lors d
accidents de travail que ce soit au
niveau du crâne que ce soit au niveau du
rachis ce les sujets vous initiative
très intéressante oui
un fait important est évidemment étant
donné cette nature des accidents le fait
que ce sont souvent des hommes jeunes
qui sont blessés en particulier dans les
accidents des deux roues la moyenne
d'âge est de 21 ans
dans la statistique général des fracture
du rachis ce c'est entre 20 et 30 ans
que nous avons à peu près un quart des
blessés et pilori et des périodes nous
ces accidents arrivent en pointe oui
dans la journée aux heures de pointe du
trafic
les jours essentiellement le samedi les
mois pour nous dans notre région les
quatre mois d'été les moyens du
traitement de ce genre d'affection est
essentiellement chirurgicale il est géré
rica 1 des notions importantes et et
l'urgence de la mise en eau du
traitement chirurgical lorsqu'on vite
par exemple un hématome dans d'autres
cas est toujours de toute façon parce
qu'il faut l'associer au traitement
chirurgical il ya un traitement médical
qui est important parce qu'il faut
empêcher que des lésions secondaire ne
se produise en plus de celles qui se
sont faites lors de l'accident et il
faut souvent aussi de maintenir
l'équilibré du corps parce que les
commandes centrale n'existe plus puisque
c'est le cerveau qui est lésé quelle est
leur pension de mortalité dans ces
accidents
il le il faut bien séparer les cas très
graves que nous recevons de l'ensemble
d'une statistique parce que sinon ça
sera un petit peu effrayant nous
recevons fait les adultes par exemple
une espèce de sélection et ce sont des
cas qui nous sont envoyées généralement
par d'autres hôpitaux de toute la région
alors là la mortalité est importante
elle peut aller si on considère ces cas
graves jusqu'à 40% il y a eu il faut
bien le dire des progrès qui ont été
faits par que la mortalité dans ce type
de cas était beaucoup plus important
qu'il ya une vingtaine d'années
il y a vingt lits de soins intensifs à
l'hôpital de la timone c'est là que se
joue le sort des accidentés après les
interventions ils ont besoin des soins
constants et ici les infirmières joue un
rôle capital mais la réussite est
souvent le fruit du travail de toute une
équipe
il faut dire que très souvent il ya
toute une équipe qui est investi dans ce
traitement d'abord plusieurs
neurochirurgien parce qu'il ya un de
garde chaque jour mais également les
réanimateurs qui vendent rôle important
joué et d'autres chirurgiens nous avons
la chance à la timone d'avoir tout cela
sur place un blessé est souvent un
polytraumatisé il peut avoir besoin
d'être opérée par un autre piste par un
chirurgien domine alain chirurgien
thoracique en fonction de ses légions
ici nous avons dans cet hôpital la
chance d'avoir beaucoup de matériel et
d'avoir tous ces services est une
excellente coopération doit dire entre
tous les services cet hôpital